ينضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس اخر التطورات الميدانيه
وان كان هناك اي معلومات عما يجري ايضا في
شمال القطاع ان كنتم تسمعون ايه اصوات لها
علاقه بالاشتباكات التي تدور بين المقاومه
وقوات الاحتلال شمالي
القطاع ربما تسمع هذا القصف المدفعي في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه حسن وواضح بان
القصف المدفعي اشتد في الدقائق الاخيره
على نحو لافت هو يتركز حاليا في المناطق
الشماليه في منطقه جباليا هنالك قصف منذ
ساعات الصباح ويبدو ان التركيز في الدقائق
الاخيره هو ايضا على المناطق الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه منطقه جحر الديك وكذلك في
مناطق وسط قطاع غزه ذلك ان الناطق العسكري
ايضا
يواصل ندائه للسكان الفلسطينيين في عمليه
تهجير جديده للسكان الفلسطينيين ومطالبتهم
باخلاء منازلهم ومناطقهم تحديدا سكان مخيم
البريج واحياء بدر والساحل الشمالي
والنزهه والزهراء والبراق والروضه والصفاء
ويطلب من هؤلاء الاحياء ومن سكان هذه
الاحياء اخلائها على وجه السرعه والتوجه
جنوبا الى منطقه دير البلح في عمليه
اقتلاع قصريه جديده وفي مؤشر كما يبدو على
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يسعى الى توسيع
عمليته العسكريه تحديدا في المناطق الوسطى
الان ل قطاع غزه هذه المناطق التي لم
يصلها بعد او لم يعمل فيها على نحو واسع
في الاسابيع الاخيره ومنذ انطلاق العمليه
البريه لكن واضح بان العمليات العسكريه
مستمره هنا في المناطق الشماليه حت حتى في
المناطق التي كان اعلن فيها الجيش
الاسرائيلي السيطره العمليه في جباليا وفي
حي الشجاعيه القصف مستمر وان كان متقطع
وليس بشكل شديد كما كان في الايام الماضيه
لكنه مستمر وهو يتصاعد في الساعه الاخيره
الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن عمليات تمشيط
واسعه اذا ربما تسمع هذا القصف حسن يتجد
دد حقيقه وهو قوي وهنالك ايضا غارات جويه
يبدو انها اكثر في المناطق الوسطى لقطاع
غزه
في البريج وفي نصيرات وفي غيرها من
المواقع هناك وهنالك تحليق كثيف ايضا
للطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي الجيش
الاسرائيلي يبدو انه بدا فيما يسميها
عمليات تمشيط واسعه في المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه في بيت حنون وفي بيت لهيه وكذلك
في مخيم جباليا وجباليا البلد يقول بانه
وصل الى مستودعات اسلحه ومخازن اسلحه
ومقاره تابعه لحركه حماس كما انه اشار الى
السيطره العملات ايضا على حي الشجاعيه
الذي كان يقول بانه معقل قوي وشديد اي من
جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه لكن مع ذلك رغم
هذه السيطره نحن ما نزال نرى اشتباكات
وقصف مدفعي وغرا جويه بين الحين والاخر
على هذه المواقع حتى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يشير الى انه يتوقع بان الايام القادمه
سوف تحمل معها مزيدا من القتال وقد يكون
ايضا قتالا شرسا ووجها لوجه مع الفصائل
الفلسطينيه المقاومه في هذه الاماكن ذلك
ان المقاتلين الفلسطينيين يخرجون من
فتوحات الانفاق ومن الانفاق الهجوميه
ويشتبك مع القوات الاسرائيليه ويرمونها
بالصواريخ المضاده للدروع في اك اكثر من
مكان وفي اكثر من موقع وهذا ما يشير
بطبيعه الحال الى اعداد القتلى والجرحى في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي وما يتكبده الجيش
في الايام الماضيه على هذا الصعيد وحتى
على صعيد تكبيدهم على مستوى الاليات
العسكريه المتوغلة
التي كان يسميها شبكه انفاق مربع
المسؤولين حيث قال بانها كانت تستخدم
لكبار القاده السياسيين والعسكريين
لتنقلات ولاداره العمليات العسكريه وقال
بان تدمير هذه الشبكه الهجوميه من شانها
ربما ان تؤثر على سير العمليات العسكريه
وعلى ادارتها من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه
شكرا لك الياس كران حدثتنا من غيله في غزه